I work in cancer
research where I
lead a computational
team that solves
challenges in drug development.
But that's not what
I'm here to talk about.
Like many of you, I'm really
excited to be here learning
about MLOps and tidy models
and quarto and all those things.
And I think those are
all great skills that
help you be good at your job.
However, I want to talk
to you about a skill
that I think can help
you be great at your job,
and that is creativity.
And I want to walk
you through some
of the steps that I took
in my creative process
for using R to help
design a quilt.
And hopefully that will
extend a little bit more
into how you can apply these
things to get better enjoyment
and fulfillment out of
your personal projects,
but also your day job.
And so first, I have to start
with a disclosure slide,
and my disclosure is that I'm
actually not a creative person
or I never thought
I was creative
because creative
people look like this.
They have paint coming
out of their chest.
They have light bulbs
around their head
and they're genetically
more creative.
They have creative
parents and they just
know how to solve problems and
ideas come to them from heaven.
And I went to engineering
school for almost 10 years,
and I'm good at
math, and I like it
when there's a correct answer.
And I can follow steps to
get to that correct answer.
However, I'm in an industry that
requires a lot of innovation,
and I looked around at the
people who are doing inspiring
work around me and whether those
are people that report to me
or are people who are
influential in the field.
They were very creative.
And so I, as a
good professional,
I've been on a journey over the
last some years to learn skills
and to practice
being more creative
and learning techniques to
also help teams and cultures be
more creative.
So now quilting. For those of you
who don't know what a quilt is,
it's a blanket.
And quilting has
been in practice
for thousands of years.
And what makes a quilt is
that you have three layers,
you have a top, you have
an insulating middle layer
and you have a back layer.
And to quilt, you connect
these layers together,
usually with thread, and
this can be very decorative.
It's an art form.
And personally I
got really excited
about making quilts as
art, and particularly
the modern quilting movement.
Oh, before I say that, I just
want to put this in R terms
that everyone can understand.
Quilting, it's just fabric
you cut up, you sew
together, and then
you sew it together again.
So back to modern quilting.
This is an example of a
beautiful, modern quilt.
It has these organic
shapes made out of fabric.
This one I also love.
Extremely different,
but it has this
beautiful composition
that draws your eye
around the frame.
Quilts can also play with
color, like this example, which
is really challenging
to do given that you
don't have every color in
the rainbow available to you
in fabric.
Quilts can also have
political messages or quilts
can be personal.
Like this is a self-portrait
someone made in fabric.
So I was really
excited about this.
And that brings me
to the prerequisite.
The prerequisite is that you
are excited about your work.
I don't think you need to be
the most experienced person.
So I started quilting at
the beginning of 2021.
I bought a sewing machine
a little over a year ago,
but I'm not going
to let that stop
me doing something interesting
if I'm excited about it.
So the first step in
my creative process
is to come up with
too many ideas.
I'm somebody that I like
to come up with one idea
and then execute
the crap out of it.
Like, don't keep thinking
about other things.
But my new method is that I
try to come up with more ideas
than I think I need.
I have an idea quota
where I come up
with 10 ideas, 40 ideas,
50 ideas, and then
from that you end
up with new ideas
that you had never
originally thought on day one
and also takes you in
directions that lets
you better curate your ideas.
And what I ended up
doing with this project
was coming up with a solution
where I could fuse two domains,
and I had just taken
a drawing class,
and I learned about the
concept of two point perspective.
Two point perspective is a
way to make a 3D visualization
in two dimensions like
these cuboid shapes.
And I also know about
R, and I thought, well,
I'm really excited about the
things that are happening
with generative art using R.
Could I create some sort
of landscape in this way?
A 2D projection
of a 3D landscape
using R using
something like geom_polygon()
And so with that, I was
really happy with that idea,
and I started to go forward.
So step two was I did
a lot of improvisation.
So I can start to learn, how
could I make this visualization
in R? How could I mess
around with the dimensions, how
many shapes I wanted, the size
of these, the overall aspect
ratio, the colors.
And then I had to
do a lot of research
because the fact is that
the design that I had chosen
is not easily convertible to
fabric, which is not something
that I had planned for.
So I had to come up with
some techniques that
would allow me to construct
my design in fabric.
And that is where I want
to talk to you a little bit
about a technique I really
like, which is called
foundation paper piecing.
It's a little bit
of a rabbit hole
I'll go down with you.
So this is a technique
where you create a design
and you print it on
a piece of paper.
So you have a design like this
and you actually sequentially
sew fabric to that design.
So this is what the
back would look like.
And then the front
looks like this.
And this is an amazing
technique because it
allows you to do very, very
precise piecing of fabrics
together.
Those lines are all
perfectly parallel.
You can have very,
very small pieces.
And this lends itself very much
to the technique and the design
that I wanted to make.
But there's a problem in
that this technique also
imparts a new geometrical
constraint and the type
of the design you can create.
So you can only add one
piece of fabric at a time
and you can only add one seam
at a time, which seems simple,
but it does impose a constraint
on the amount of design
that you can do.
So for something like my
design, I'm in trouble
because this is not pieceable.
This design, with this y
junction in the middle,
I cannot do because I would
have to add two pieces of fabric
at the same time.
It doesn't work.
So the way that people who
design these patterns work
is it's basically
like a Sudoku puzzle.
It's all done by hand
where you look at this
and I say, well, I can't
do this in one block,
so I'll split it
into two, and then
I have to design where
my seams will go.
And then I also have to
determine the correct order,
because if I don't add these
pieces in the correct order,
it won't work.
And I really thought
a lot about, okay, well,
is there a way I could use
R or some other framework
to help me do this?
And I found a
wonderful paper that
was published just last year
by Mackenzie Leake and others
at Stanford University,
which actually
gets into the mathematical
foundation for doing this.
And I really recommend,
if you're interested,
to go ahead and read this paper.
They've also got some YouTube
videos and even a web app
that you can use to help
design your own designs.
And so I don't really want
to talk about graph theory,
although I do a little bit,
which is that these designs are
then represented as hyper
graphs, where each piece is
a node in the graph and
each seam is an edge.
And this allows you
then to determine
if your design is
pieceable and also
automatically derive the order
that you would add the pieces.
It's really cool.
So if we take a complicated
design like the one
I made of the R
logo on the left,
that's actually four pieces.
And I can represent
them as four graphs.
And from that I can determine
that my design was good
because it was pieceable
and also the order
that I need to add the pieces.
So that was great.
I'm good, except for now
I have to make the quilt.
And execution is a really
hard part of creativity
because if you just
have a lot of ideas
and you don't actually follow
through and finish them,
that's a problem.
So I started to work
on my sewing machine
and I worked on it for a while.
And one of the
things that I think
is really helpful as part
of a creative process
is to seek advice
or collaboration.
So here I actually went
on quilting reddit,
of course that exists,
and I posted my quilt
and asked "somebody
give me some ideas here.
I'm kind of stuck."
And people were really generous.
They gave me these
schematics back like, hey,
try this, try that,
which was fantastic.
Another thing that
is part of executing
is that you're going
to make mistakes.
And the interesting thing
about a visual art like quilting
is that your
mistakes are visceral
and they're hard to hide.
So in my git repo, I can
kind of hide my mistakes,
although I don't.
I usually write like,
"big mistake," "big mess,"
"clean this up."
But when I have
something physical,
that mistake is there.
And I think it
helps you get better
at making mistakes
because you can see them
and you can be like, it's OK.
It's part of growing
and learning.
And so then this
is the other part
that's really hard is that
you have to share your work.
So I did bring
this quilt with me.
And I have to put this mic down.
So I think.
Here we go. [applause]
Thank you for humoring
me, but I think
this is one of the first
ggplots ever made in fabric.
Probably not the first,
but one of the first.
But there is another step,
which is that oftentimes you
find that the question you
were asking when you started
is not actually the
most important question
or the right question that
you should have been asking.
And that definitely
happened here.
I started off and I
thought like, yeah,
I'll just make a plot and
then I'll make it in fabric.
That's the right question.
And I came up with
these other ideas,
which are really interesting
research that I could actually
be performing as
part of this process.
Everything from like, how do
I choose the right colors?
How do I determine
how much fabric
to order to how do I try
to design these blocks more
intelligently?
So that's one of the
future work that I'm
working on at the moment.
For example, the R logo is
really hard to make as a quilt.
It has some curve shapes,
it has some square shapes.
Really difficult to represent
that actually in fabric.
So I could do something
sort of naive here.
I can create a
pixelated design, which
I think it's
actually pretty cool,
but it doesn't really
look like the R logo
to me, so I wasn't
happy with that.
So then I can do this, which is
just I kind of, mostly by hand,
generated this pattern.
And I think that's great.
I think it looks
just like the R logo.
So success story,
except if I wanted
to go a step further and have
the code generate this for me,
that's what I'm working on.
And if you're a
close observer, you
can see that this
doesn't look right.
You don't have to humor me.
It's not right.
But from this I am
learning a lot, right?
There's a process here and I'm
learning interesting things
and I think it's leading
in different directions.
I can take that kind of thing,
and I can make a self
portrait of myself.
I'm working on other approaches
where I can have code generate
a design, but as well
the fabric choices
that you could use.
So now that I've
described the process,
I have to be honest with you,
I didn't describe it entirely
in that, I kind of made up the order.
For the purpose of the talk,
I thought it would be helpful to
say like one, two, three, four,
five, six.
But in reality, that's not the
order that I did these things.
And that's true with a
lot of creative work,
whether you're doing it for your
day job or for your art projects,
generally, it's a very
non-linear process,
which is something
that I personally
struggle with
because I would like
it to be a linear process
with like a right answer,
but that's something that can
help you strengthen your work.
OK so I want to now talk about
a couple tortured metaphors
that I've learned
from other people
that I think apply to my work
in computational research
and hopefully also will
resonate with some of you
and the kind of work
that you do and how you
could try to be more creative.
So this first example, I
learned from a colleague of mine
at BMS, Joe Szustakowski,
and the question is,
would you rather be a pizza
deliverer or would you
rather be a plumber?
I'll let people think.
What does it--how
do you get pizza?
I order pizza a
lot and it's great.
I can get on my phone, I can
say what toppings I want,
how many pizzas, and
then I get a photo
of the pizza on my doorstep.
It's incredible, right?
It works really, really
well for food delivery.
But I've also been on teams
where I'm a data analyst
and I'm asked for things in
the same way. Somebody goes on
and they order a data pizza.
They say, I need this
dashboard with these features,
with this data.
And I don't think that's a very
effective way to do data work.
I don't think that's a good
way for you to get insights
from data.
And it doesn't leave any
room for creativity or trying
to get to what are really the
right questions you should
be asking.
So a slight iteration on that
is to think about a plumber.
So a plumber is a subject
matter expert, right?
I have a plumber
come to my house
and they talk to me about
what my problems are.
They bring their own tool kit,
they have their own expertise,
and they try to understand
really what my needs are.
And they work on a solution
that will meet my needs.
OK So if you don't like
that one, that's fine.
I have another one.
So this one is
Would you rather be a
detective or a criminal?
and it's a trick question,
you actually want to be both.
So this is actually one
from Albert Einstein.
And so this is about explaining
why science is so difficult.
So if you take a detective
like a Sherlock Holmes,
a murder's been
committed and you collect clues
and you have hypotheses like
it's a jealous girlfriend,
it's an ex-colleague
or whatever.
And you put together
all these clues
and then you discover
like, oh, actually it
was a poisonous jellyfish
that killed the person.
Like, that's how a
detective works, right?
But the key is that
a detective knows
what crime they're solving.
The problem is
really well defined.
This person's been murdered.
This has been stolen.
I know how to solve it.
But the difference
is for a scientist,
you have to also come
up with the questions.
So in that way, you
have to commit the crime
and you have to perform
the investigation.
And I find this is a really
apt metaphor for the work
that I do, because you have
to constantly be asking,
am I asking the right questions?
Is this the important
line of research
that I should be following?
And I think that's a really,
really important part
of doing science that
requires you to be creative.
So to wrap those thoughts up, I
would say you should be a plumber.
You should also
commit science crimes.
And I would also
encourage you to think
about celebrating
your mistakes and also
getting exposure to new ideas.
So I think at
meetings like this,
it's great to go to
talks that you might not
think would be interesting.
I would also encourage
you to find your local
R user group, R
Ladies group or meetup group,
to try to attend talks and
meet people that you might not
normally meet in your day job.
With that, I have some
acknowledgments or resources
if you're interested in
learning more about creativity.
And this is also a work
in progress that I have,
and you might recognize
that that is geom_point().
All right.
Thank you.